into market takes it's a live stream for
the wall street journal i am dionne
robowen markets reporter at the wall
street journal uh if you are a long
investor on the stock market if you were
someone betting that stock prices are
going to rise
whoo it's a rough monday to start the
week after a rough
five-week stretch for you where we have
really just seen nothing but red across
the stock market that's the dow the s p
500 the nasdaq the russell
everywhere you look you're seeing
selling and you know that could be
coming to an end this week we've got
some data that could put a positive spin
on the market and really give investors
something to be excited about and a
reason to buy
or it could give investors more reasons
to sell continue or even worsen the
sell-off that we're seeing right now
this morning and that we have seen like
i said for five straight weeks on the s
p 500 for six straight weeks on the dow
so
want to get into all that we're going to
talk about what's making the market move
why we're seeing this massive sell-off
across the stock market we're also going
to talk about the two big reports that
we've got coming this week that's the
consumer price index and the producer
price index basically how much prices
are increasing for businesses and how
much they're increasing for consumers
you and i how much more we're spending
every time we go to the store pay rent
go to the pump all that good and
not so good in the last few months stuff
so let's talk about the market let's
talk about what we're seeing that's got
us here on this day where we are down
checking in on wsj.com the nasdaq still
down about 2.7
today uh monday may 9th 2022
you're seeing the dow is only down about
1.15 percent and the s p right in
between down about 2 today that
continues a sell-off that we saw last
week that was five straight weeks that
is the longest uh sell-off that's the
longest weekly consecutive sell-off
streak for the s p 500 in more than 10
years the last time we saw selling like
this was june 2011.
uh so we're talking about more than 10
years the dow is down almost 10 or sorry
excuse me the s p 500 is down almost 10
in those five weeks year to date down
about 14
put that in context we again reached
correction territory last week the s p
500 officially in a correction uh so
we're having a market correction the
nasdaq though doing even worse it has
wiped away all of its gains uh from 2021
and obviously from 2022 we are now down
to those levels where last we were
sitting in november of 2020. so again
you're seeing a long-term five weeks now
sell-off in the market wiping away those
gains from all of 2021 which was a
pretty strong year on the s p 500 so i
want to thank you all again for tuning
into the live stream we're talking
markets we're talking cpi ppi those big
inflation reports that we've got coming
out this week and i'm going to tell you
why those could turn this thing around
maybe get some buyers back in the market
or could potentially aggravate the
selling make it even worse
and remember um we're now in may we are
coming off in april that was in april to
forget for uh stock long term or long
long stock investors the worst month we
had since march 2020 if you remember
march 2020 things were not good at all
the nasdaq lost 13 just in the month of
april that was its worst month since
october 2008 the worst april the nasdaq
has had since 2000. again this is all
really going back to yields on the
treasury market the two-year treasury
note yield
went up by almost 200 basis points 197
basis points on the two-year on the
10-year 163 basis points if you aren't
familiar with the u.s treasury mark you
don't watch it just know that that is
huge the worst start to a year that we
have ever seen in the treasury and in
the bond market so a real
magnitude shifting
change that we're seeing across the bond
market and especially in those u.s
treasury markets which is government
debt
that's a big big deal and we're seeing
that kind of continue into the start of
may today yields are down a little bit
but definitely a consistent theme that
we have seen treasury yields going up
which means prices are going down stock
prices going down along with them
also so we're going to talk about cpi
and ppi but i want to tell you about the
sneaky important report to watch this
week and that is the import export
prices that we're going to get on friday
definitely something to keep your eye on
and i think that's going to be a report
that doesn't get a lot of hype going
into it but definitely one to watch
because
when we got that u.s gdp report which
was negative for the first quarter a big
part of that was the increase in imports
here in the u.s and you know we didn't
see a commensurate increase in exports
we just saw the things that we're buying
from overseas that's what sinks usgdp
i'm going to break that down and get
into that a little bit later on so look
all this goes back to the federal
reserve right they had their meeting
their may meeting last week uh fed chair
jerome powell said that a 75 basis point
rate hike wasn't on the table
essentially that means that they'd be
raising rates by three times the typical
level
so going three times as fast on the rate
hikes as they typically do he said
that's really not on the table it's not
something we're actively considering the
market took a lot of joy and excitement
from that
but it was just one day so wednesday we
saw the stocks shoot up i think uh the s
p 500 in the day up about two percent
the nasdaq up more than that two and a
half to three percent um stocks just
really jumping in a sort of fit of
euphoria and the very next day thursday
we saw that sell-off continue we saw
that again on friday and it looks like
we're seeing it again today it looks
like investors are saying yeah okay
maybe a 75 point rate hike isn't on the
table isn't three times as high but if
you're still going to be hiking twice as
fast at multiple meetings as you did in
may fed raised rates by 50 basis points
again two times as fast as normal if
you're going to be doing that in may and
june and july potentially out to
september well you're still raising
rates at a super fast uh pace you're
still going on an accelerated clip
and that's likely to weigh on the
economy and weigh on a lot of these
companies that have borrowed a lot of
money look the big picture when you step
back and look at it is companies
especially a lot of these high-flying
tech companies they've brought a lot of
money and they don't have a lot of
profits a lot of them are what you call
zombie companies which means they don't
even make enough in profit to pay off
the to make the payments on the debt
that they have so when you can't make
your payments on the debt that means you
go into default and the creditors and
the vultures they come in and they start
taking what they can and what they can
get so that's the situation a lot of
these high-flying tech companies are in
and a lot of folks in the market are
saying
this this isn't looking good rates are
just going to keep going up inflation is
going to stay high for a while that's
going to mean you uh mr high flying tech
company ceo are going to be in a pickle
and we don't want to own your stock
so that's that was big because powell
said okay no 75 basis point rate hike
but we still are going to do what we
need to do to get inflation under
control now one big piece from that
press conference i don't think got as
much attention as it should have was fed
chair powell has been saying we think we
can engineer a soft landing we think
that we can you know rain rates in
without doing a lot of damage to the
economy without doing a lot of damage to
the labor market we're going to have a
soft landing well at the last meeting
during the press conference he said no a
soft dish landing we might have a soft
or soft dish and i think that soft dish
is what's got a lot of folks on edge
because now the fed is supposed to
convey confidence to the market the
fetish will say hey we've got everything
under control
everything's all good guys just settle
down let us let us handle this now
they're saying well maybe we won't
and just before that you had three
former federal reserve presidents one
from the new york fed very important mr
bill dudley also from the richmond fed
also from the philly fed saying we don't
think there's going to be a soft landing
it would be very hard if not impossible
the words mr dudley used were next to
impossible to actually have this soft
landing which means likely a recession
which means likely a lot of economic
pain
so that all happened on wednesday and
we've seen the market reaction since
then
to what the federal reserve has said
so that leads us into what we've got
coming up next here on the live stream
and again thank you all for tuning in we
talked about the market response the
market reaction we talked about what
happened at that fed meeting last week
now we're going to look ahead to this
week when we get cpi the consumer price
index and why that matters so if you
remember the cpi for march was eight and
a half percent eight point five percent
that's the highest we've seen in about
40 years so the fed is saying we're not
going to do this 75 basis point increase
but we're still going to be raising
rates we're going to be dependent on
inflation well if inflation picks up and
comes in higher than expected right now
the expectation is for
cpi to reach about 8 8.1 according to
economists that have been surveyed and
have been tracked by factset if we come
in lower than that well things are all
good it means inflation's slowing down
we're hitting that peak that the fed has
been calling for and saying that we're
going to get that most economists expect
but if it comes in higher if it comes in
especially above that eight and a half
percent number that we got in march well
that means the economy is in big trouble
that inflation is not only stickier but
it's rising continually and the fed is
going to have to do more that means
another 75 foot basis point rate height
could definitely be on the table and we
could be talking about one full
percentage point as in raising rates by
one percent that would be really big now
economists think that we've hit the peak
of inflation because the month
month-over-month increase on core
inflation when you strip out volatile
food volatile energy prices which tend
to move a lot
when they just look at what's you know
housing
prices for consumer goods things like
that that rate is slowing down
and and generally it's it's peaking out
the other thing is that the comparisons
to where inflation was back in april of
2021 well it was a lot higher than it
was in march and in february and in
january so you saw that pickup and
inflation start to rise at a rapid clip
last year around this time and so you're
dealing with higher inflation and you're
comparing yourselves to a higher number
so that's why economists are partially
expecting those two things or why
economists are expecting inflation is
going to cool down or at least the rate
of increase is going to start to cool
down as we move throughout this year if
that doesn't happen definitely look for
some big headlines and some big moves in
the stock market and we also get the
producer price index that's coming out
on thursday cpi is on wednesday 8 30 a.m
i think that's gonna be must-see tv so
be there or be a
on on thursday we get the ppi the
producer price index report
that's not as heavily followed but in
march we got a record high and we've
seen producer prices lead consumer
prices as businesses have continued to
be able to raise rates as their costs
rise so they're passing those costs on
the consumers
and we also have seen
you know if these problems for
businesses continue in terms of hiring
in terms of on the labor front having to
pay more for wages having to pay more
for commodities all the inputs they need
they're passing those on to consumers so
will we see producer prices continue and
will we see that lead continue where you
know when producer prices go up this
much consumer prices seem to go up that
much as well that's a big question what
we saw from the jobs report on friday
suggests that businesses are still
having some trouble we saw in the jolts
report on tuesday a job openings in
march were a record high again but you
saw less higher so more job openings
less people being hired for those jobs
you saw a new record for quits meaning
the great resignation maybe that's still
continuing still going on
is that going to factor into business
costs being increased you did see on the
jobs report that we got on friday that
average hourly earnings number kind of
start to come down a little bit but
average hourly earnings year over year
still about five and a half percent
that's still very high and it's
something that the fed excuse me it's
something the federal reserve and lots
of other economists have pointed to as a
reason why higher inflation might stick
around because those labor costs are
stickier think about it if you got a
five and a half percent raise this year
you're not going to want a three percent
raise next year or if you switch jobs
and you were making you know five and a
half times what you were making at your
previous job well to go to another job
you're gonna want an even bigger race so
those labor costs tend to be sticky and
that's a reason that
economists worry about these numbers on
that we saw in the jobs report on friday
um again ppi the producer price index
hit a record high in march uh producer
prices prices for businesses were up by
more than 11
in march year over year that is a big
number and if that continues to spring
higher it's going to be hard for those
consumer prices to come down because
businesses and companies have inflation
on their side when consumers see prices
going up everywhere well it's easier for
businesses to raise their prices and
that feeds into this kind of vicious
cycle that we start to see
now that's ppi and cpi those are the big
numbers i think those are going to be
the big market movers this week no
question about it but if you're someone
who is you know keen to watch what's
really going on in the economy what's
you know what's going on underneath the
covers a little bit i urge you to look
at this import and export prices report
that we get on friday
a big part of the negative gdp report
that we got for the first quarter was
that was the fact that we had so many
more imports the imports that we were
getting were more expensive and we
bought more of them a lot of that is
just because u.s consumers are spending
more but
most imports are fairly cheap that's why
we import things because it's cheaper
than what we can make here so if people
are buying a lot of imports means
they're buying a lot of cheap products
the people who are buying those cheap
products generally the lower income
folks folks the lower end of the income
scale and when they're doing a lot of
buying well that means that they're
trying to save money usually if you've
got a lot of folks saving money trying
or trying to save money at least buying
cheaper things well usually that's a
sign that things in the economy not so
great so definitely keep a look for that
import export price number on friday we
also get the university of michigan's
consumer sentiment index look out for
that because again we've been at the
lowest rate in about 10 years all year
this year numbers picked up a little bit
uh in april but is that going to
continue will we see continued increase
or will things go back to being worse
are consumers really just starting to
throw in the towel on buying so i want
to thank you again for tuning in to
market takes dionne bowen from the wall
street journal here with you if you're
watching for your first time thank you
and i hope you'll be with us again next
monday if you're a regular viewer
appreciate you tuning in again and you
know we will be back like i said next
monday to do this all again we talked
about the stock market sell-off we
talked about what you need to watch this
week cpi and ppi also those import and
export prices i think are going to be a
very big deal this week especially if
you're one if you're on recession watch
like i know a lot of folks are so thanks
for being with us here on market takes
and we'll see